[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Your program indicates
an intermission,
but that is not true.
I just have to say, the
two saxophone pieces
that you heard so beautifully
played, that's all them.
They picked the music.
They did all the rehearsing.
And I think they did a
fabulous job doing all that.
[APPLAUSE]
I welcome you.
My name is Fred Harrison,
director of wind and jazz
ensembles here at MIT.
And although somewhat subtle and
somewhat not, what you heard,
those three pieces, is
actually a little bit
of a tribute to John McLellan.
Wow.
Already?
So I want to-- before I get
to that-- thank a few people.
Some things will be
happening behind me.
And so I'm going to talk while
those things are happening.
I hope those things are
starting to happen now.
Are they?
Would be the cue,
start coming out now.
While the full ensemble
makes its way to stage--
cue-- I want to thank
some key people who
have been at the heart
of our support system
this entire academic year.
Cuco Daglio, MIT Music and
Theater Arts multimedia
specialist.
You clap at the end.
Tony DeBartolo, our
recording engineer.
Kyleena Shallenberger
and her husband
Isaiah, administrators for MTA.
Michael Carmichael, oh, boy,
it's a long day and night.
Michelle Carmichael,
administrative officer for MTA.
Larry Gallagher and his entire
MIT video productions team that
has made the dream of
streaming performances
possible with the support
of Neil and Jane Pappalardo.
On May 11th, we have a
unique musical event.
You might see it on the
back of your program.
You might have seen a rather
large poster up front.
The Great Clarinet Summit.
How many of you
already have tickets
to the Great Clarinet Summit?
I'll say half of you for our
visiting audience online.
What is this concert?
Yes, things are continuing
to happen behind me.
So this is-- I'm not
aware of any other concert
quite like this
that has happened.
I won't go as far as
to say there's never
been a concert like this,
but it could be the case.
We have five major clarinet
soloists, three of whom
have been longstanding
jazz icons
of the clarinet for many years.
Billy Novick is a
Boston jazz institution.
Clarinetist from
Lexington, Mass has
been doing all of the
major clarinet jazz
work in the Boston
area for 30 years.
Don Byron has been on the
scene, a graduate of New England
Conservatory, has been on the
scene for at least 30 years
and really one of the most
innovative and eclectic
and soulful musicians
on the music scene.
Anat Cohen, Israeli-born
fantastic clarinetist
is newer to the scene
and has been tearing up
that scene in the world of
jazz and improvisational music.
So that's three people.
That would seem to be enough,
right, for a clarinet summit?
But yet, we have two incredible
clarinetist on our faculty.
Eran Egozy is newly
on our faculty,
the last couple of years.
Is a fantastic classical
clarinetist and founder
of the Radius Chamber
Ensemble around town.
And in his spare
time, he creates
things like Guitar Hero
and also just newly
a new Boston Symphony Orchestra
program, online program note
system.
And of course, there
is Evan Ziporyn,
who is one of the
leading clarinet
players in the world,
particularly the bass clarinet.
But really has
his own ensembles.
Performs with Yo-Yo
Ma, among many others.
And as I say, happens to be our
faculty head and chair, who's
been on this faculty
for 25 years.
And then on the poster
it says and you.
And you.
So how many of you play
the clarinet out there?
Raise your hand.
OK, how many of you have already
signed up for the summit?
How many of you don't know
what I'm talking about?
How many of you are fearful?
So if you play the
clarinet, you're thinking,
I'm going to play
with all these people?
You just went on and on
about how wonderful they are.
How am I going to
play with them?
I've been playing
for five years.
for three years.
I've been playing for 45 years.
And I'm in the Boston Symphony.
Well, guess what?
You can all play on this concert
because a fabulous musician,
who I will introduce
a little bit later,
Jamshied Sharifi
composed a piece
called "Ornament Of The World"
that, in fact, will feature
all five of these clarinetists,
plus Ini Oguntola,
who is part of the inspiration
for the whole clarinet summit.
He's a junior here at MIT and
a fabulous improvisational
clarinetist.
And the MIT Wind Ensemble and
the MIT Festival Jazz Ensemble.
Somehow we will
often on this stage.
And then I think we're up
to 70 people signed up now.
I'm dreaming of 200 clarinets.
I know it sounds scary, but
it's going to be beautiful.
200 clarinets will be aligned.
And they will play
in this piece.
How does that happen?
Well, my goodness
we're all ready.
This is very exciting.
OK, I can stop the commercial
for the clarinet summit now.
And I know you
wanted more, but I
believe there's a very
full MIT Wind Ensemble.
And you might see faces that
are slightly older than college
students.
And that's because we have
sixth, seventh, and eighth
graders from the Chenery
Middle School here.
[APPLAUSE]
They are here to honor
John McLellan, who
is fantastic music educator
from the Belmont Public Schools.
And he's retiring this year
after 35 years in Belmont
and a number of years
in other places.
Before I don't tell you
what we're going to play,
I want to say something
about John McLellan.
The MIT Wind Ensemble has
collaborated with the Chenery
Middle School on
numerous occasions
over the last 10, 15 years.
And I've personally been
collaborating with John
since 1987, first interning
at the Chenery School,
and then later
teaching alongside him
in the Belmont Public Schools.
He's one of my dearest
friends and colleagues
and among the greatest
musicians and music educators
I've been privileged to know
and learn from and continue
to learn from.
His teaching legacy
in Belmont is
rooted in excellence,
creativity, kindness,
deep dedication, and true caring
for each individual student.
And there have been
thousands of them.
I'd like to invite two of
them to come to the stage
to say a little bit about
one facet of John's teaching
that they'd like to talk about.
Please welcome Tilly
Jones and Irene Son.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hello, my name is Irene.
This is Tilly.
And we are here with the
Chenery Wind Ensemble
to celebrate our
teacher, John McLellan,
and his accomplishments over
the past 35 years of teaching
at the Chenery Middle School.
I'm an eighth grader at Chenery.
And Mr. McLellan's
been my teacher
for the past five years now.
The levels, which are the
reason we are here today,
are a series of exercises that
Mr. McLellan created in 1999
in order to challenge his
students to take music
to another level.
In order to pass
the levels, you have
to record yourself
playing the exercise.
Then submit them to Mr.
McLellan or Miss Phipps.
Then they would decide whether
the level is good enough
to pass, or they would
send it back to you
so that you could try it again.
Once you've passed
the basic 10 levels,
then Mr. McLellan writes an
individualized level for you
that includes
skills that he feels
will push you forward
as a musician.
In total, Mr. McLellan's
written over 550 levels that
are all different in some way.
And Tilly and I have each
passed about 110 levels.
And people ask us why do
you pass so many levels?
And to be really honest, we had
to sit down and think about it
for a second.
After thinking about
it for a long time,
we came to the conclusion
that there are really
two main reasons.
The first reason is
that Mr. McLellan
has helped us to learn
the feeling of achievement
and Mr. McLellan's
endless efforts
to keep up with all of us.
And it has encouraged
us to keep playing music
and reach for our goals.
The levels are a unique way
to practice our instruments.
And because all the levels
are different and challenging
in their own way, it makes it
more interesting to practice
the levels.
I, as a player, have
improved very much.
And I'm sure others here
feel the same way as I do.
Mr. McLellan's writing has
really inspired us all.
And the time and
thought that he devotes
into writing each and every
level for all of his students
is really incredible.
[APPLAUSE]
The second reason
we do levels is
because levels are a way
that Mr. McLellan connects
with his students.
Mr. McLellan knows everyone.
He doesn't just know their name
and what instrument they play.
He understands
everyone's personality.
And he knows how dedicated
to music they are.
He knows so much
about everyone he's
able to write a piece of
music that is specifically
made to match their strengths,
weaknesses, and character.
So many people I know
have just done the levels
so that they could have a piece
of music specifically written
for them written by
their favorite teacher.
Mr. McLellan has
written over 550 levels,
and so many people ask us
why we've done 110 levels.
And although we've
done 110, we've
only passed a fifth of
the amount of levels
he's actually written.
Mr. McLellan is one of the
most hardworking and inspiring
teachers we've ever had.
And we all just
want to thank him
for making the Chenery a better
place for the past 35 years.
[APPLAUSE]
So I'm not going to tell you
what we're about to play.
I will tell you that the
composer is John McLellan.
The arranger is Kenneth Amos.
The commissioning body of
this three movement work
is POMS, Parents of Music
Students, Belmont's community
and music support group.
And we thank them for
making what you about
to hear possible.
And I want to thank POMS'
president, Kimberly Carlisle.
And particularly, Cindy
Estes, membership chairperson
of POMS who has been
at the front lines
for this whole project.
Lastly, a huge thanks
to Sharon Phipps,
John's co-director of
the Chenery School, who
put enormous energy, both
logistically and musically
into this whole project.
I also just want to thank
the Chenery sixth, seventh,
and eighth graders who
participated in this--
50 of them.
They're amazing young
people, as you will hear.
And you've already heard.
And it was just a
complete joy for me
to come back home, as
it were, to Belmont.
Amazing young people.
Please enjoy this
three movement tribute
to John McLellan
arranged by Kenneth Amos
and performed by the Chenery
and MIT Wind Ensembles.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
How many of you
are from Belmont?
[CHEERS]
And there's 50
people behind me that
knew all about this and
yet, not a word was spoken.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
And as I recognize levels
seven, eight, and nine,
thankfully I stopped at level
five writing them for band.
So now, I don't have
to worry about those.
And I believe the woodwind
quintet a couple of months
ago played level six.
There you go.
So we're almost done, everyone.
Where's Ken Amos?
Ken Amos?
Come on, Ken Amos.
He's up in the booth, actually.
He can't come down.
I would have hidden
there too, Ken.
Congrats.
Well, thank you
immensely, Ken Amos.
But where's Sharon Phipps?
She's not getting out of this.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
Sharon, if you don't
want to speak in the mic,
maybe get Tilly and
Irene to talk for you.
I am deeply impressed.
Thank you very much, students
of Belmont, students of MIT,
and the amazing Dr. Harris.
But most of all, Sharon
Phipps, everyone.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
Now it's intermission.
[APPLAUSE]